c'est un des sujets qui ne voudra pas
disparaître aux États-Unis comme
ailleurs ici on a eu aussi ce sujet-là
qui qui est venu avec le chemin Roxane à
l'époque mais c'est un sujet plus large
en Europe
donnez moi votre appréciation du niveau
de la crise politique pour Joe Biden au
sud de la frontière ne serait-ce pas
vertu de l'ampleur du problème parce que
vous avez raison le souligner d'emblée
c'est un problème qui est mondial on
n'est pas seulement ça la frontière
entre le Mexique et les États-Unis ma
vertu de l'ampleur à cette frontière
c'est un problème qui est considérable
écoutez en 2021 la première année
complète de Monsieur Biden à la
présidence on a battu un record en
approchant en fait un frôlant le cap des
1,6 millions d'appréhension là il y a
seulement question d'appréhension il y a
pas question de migrants au total qu'on
n'a pas appréhendé potentiellement ce
mode d'appréhension la frontière entre
les deux pays et tout le monde
évidemment criait à la crise parce que
c'était énorme comme nombre or en 2022
l'année suivante l'année dernière
écoutez on a dépassé le cap des deux
virgule 7 millions on a presque doublé
ce qui était déjà un record donc
évidemment que c'est considérable il
faut réaliser ceci évidemment que c'est
seulement ce sont seulement quatre États
qui partagent la français avec le
Mexique le Nouveau Mexique l'Arizona le
Texas mais la réalité c'est que
justement parce que tellement de monde
qui traverse la frontière il sera à peu
près partout aux États-Unis donc ça
devient une crise qui est non seulement
régionale pour Monsieur Biden mais qui
est vraiment d'envergure nationale et
qui excessivement difficile à régler et
là avec
les changements de règles post
pandémique c'était plus facile avec le
titre 42 de renvoyer les gens là ça sera
plus difficile ce qui on verra sera plus
difficile mais en tout cas le message
que c'est envoyé pour beaucoup de gens
c'est on va on va s'essayer on va y
aller là et c'est là la raison
principale évidemment pour laquelle on
en parle tant notamment dans les médias
américains surtout dans les médias
américains mais même ici cette semaine
parce que c'est cette semaine qu'on a
formellement levé se décrire sincèrement
c'est un décret qui datait de la fin de
la présidence Trump le début de la
pandémie donc on donnait disons une
façon plus facile de renvoyer au Mexique
les migrants qu'on interceptait du côté
américain de la frontière à partir
risible même de comparer la situation
voir la crise du creuset qu'on a dans
notre côté de la frontière avec celle à
l'autre entière celle entre les
États-Unis et le Mexique et il y a pas
simplement une question ou c'est pas
simplement une question du nombre de
migrants présentement et aussi une
question temporelle c'est que cette
crise là qu'on l'appelle officiellement
crise depuis deux ans ou un an et demi
ou deux ans et demi c'est assez
secondaire à la réalité c'est qu'il y a
un énorme en fait il y a d'énormes
problèmes migratoires à cette
frontière-là qui date même maintenant
non pas de moi non pas d'années Patrice
mais de décennies c'est ça qu'il faut
réaliser c'est que la question
migratoire les questions migratoires
c'est de nature de juridiction fédérale
aux États-Unis et une administration
après l'autre on pourrait commencer au
minimum avec celle de Monsieur Clinton
donc monsieur Clinton monsieur Bosch
monsieur Trump monsieur Biden ont tous
promis de s'adresser de front aux
problèmes et ont tous échoué de façon
fondamentale donc c'est un problème qui
prend de l'ampleur parce qu'il n'est pas
réglé dans le temps ça aussi comment le
régler il y en a un qui avait une idée à
l'époque on s'en souvient dans notre
chambre avait dit je vais vous le régler
le problème je vais créer un mur que je
vais faire payer par les Mexicains en
plus Donald Trump qui était sur CNN
cette semaine grand retour de Trump sur
le son son réseau Oni qu'il n'aimait pas
du tout
quatre langues se la vedette montante du
CNN qui l'a reçu dans un temps RAL et là
sur la question existentielle est-ce
qu'il croit encore que l'élection de
Biden a été truquée ou pas je vous
propose d'écouter ça Raphaël mesdames et
messieurs on vient tout de suite
ici
pouvez-vous nous dire demande Corinne ou
président Trump que vous avez perdu
l'élection s'il vous plait
si vous faites ce qu'on peut revenir
dans le réel puis après ça on aura des
différences mais au moins ça puis il dit
non pas du tout mais non mais en même
temps Patrice est-ce que quelqu'un la
moindre personne que suivie ne serait-ce
qu'un soupçon politique américaine
depuis les trois dernières années et qui
est surpris ou surprise de cette réponse
là en fait le contraire aurait été
carrément renversant qu’après tout ce
temps-là dans notre chambre nos conseils
ne serait-ce qu'un pouce donc évidemment
que le discours ne change pas et soit en
passant c'est sûr qu'on a seulement le
temps de faire jouer un ou quelques
extrêmes mais la réalité c'est que vous
prenez l'ensemble de l'événement qu'on a
eu mercredi soir c'était quoi c'était à
peu près 70 minutes le grosso modo ça a
été du Trump tout craché du début à la
fin incluant mais non pas de façon
exhaustive ses propos sur l'élection en
guillemets voler ce qui soit en passant
Patrice d'un point de vue médiatique ça
c'est vraiment fascinant est en train de
créer une énorme révolte interne
carrément chez sionnel et au sein de
l'auditoire régulier de CNN parce qu'il
faut comprendre que la relation assez
tendue entre Trump et le réseau était
pas une latérale c'est-à-dire que depuis
des années on a disons une couverture
qui est particulièrement critique on va
dire comme ça passionnel de Donald Trump
donc c'était personnel en fait je vous
ai très candidat je n'avais pas vu
autant de propos et d'intervenants
trumpiste ou pro Trump depuis la
campagne de 2016 donc pour l'auditoire
régulier tianen ça fait un sacré choc et
le président du réseau depuis les 24-48
dernières heures est essentiellement en
gestion de crise pour essayer de
justifier la décision même d'avoir tenu
l'événement en direct avec Monsieur
Trump devant un public qui lui était
largement conquis d'avance donc il y a
cette dynamique
je sais pas ce que vous dites mais moi
on ne dit pas que Collins n'a pas été
bonne ne pas essayer elle a été elle a
posé les questions qu'on devait poser
mais il y avait il y avait un auditoire
très pro Trump lui bougea Paul comme
vous avez dit dans un iota et on se
demande le calcul de CNN on est les
primaires républicaines arrivent
c'est ça reste une entreprise privée
c'est là qu'on le voit mais exactement
c'est payant il faut le dire de façon
très franche c'est une relation qu'au
dépendante entre Donald Trump et les
conglomérats privés médiatique aux
États-Unis il demeure encore une fois
parce qu'ils ne change pas de style
absolument irrésistible d'un point de
vue médiatique donc il y a ça d'un côté
c'est ça que d'un point de vue de code
d'écoute il y a une statut professionnel
de le mettre en ordre si j'avais pas vu
les cotes je les ai pas vu je ne les ai
pas vu en fait j'en ai entendu parler je
ne les ai pas confirmé je vais de façon
très très prudente là j'ai entendu
quelque chose autour des 3 millions il
faudrait que je la Valette de mon côté
mais dans tous les cas ce qui va être
intéressant de voir justement c'est que
si c'est vraiment un exercice
journalistique ok sans justement arrière
pensée ou arrière but pour aller
chercher des codes d'écoute et que c'est
pour former l'auditoire républicain en
vue des primaires républicaines la
réalité c'est que le réseau aura pas le
choix d'organiser le même genre
d'événement avec les rivaux de Monsieur
Trump et présentement Patrice il y a
absolument rien au programme à cette
affaire-là ok mais ils vont écouter les
rivaux
ça arrive au moment où Joe Biden
reçoit la Palme du président le moins
populaire de l'histoire à ce statique il
faut être très très précis à se
statistique de sa présidence parce que
des présidents qui à un moment ou un
autre de leur de leur mandat sont
devenus de son descendus beaucoup plus
bas que Monsieur Biden peut être
présentement mais ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'à ce stade ici à peu près 18 mois de
sa possible réaction monsieur Biden est
dans une position qui de façon isolée le
met dans une position
extraordinairement vulnérable à produire
de façon là aussi très très claire
Patrice il y a aucun président sortant
depuis le début des sondages modernes au
milieu du XXème siècle qui a été réélu
avec un taux d'approbation
ne serait-ce que comparable à celui de
Monsieur Biden présentement et pourquoi
on parle du taux d'approbation en
particulier parce que depuis justement
50 ans 60 ans c'est l'indicateur numéro
un pour ce qui est de la corrélation
avec le vote populaire qu'il reçoit
l'art justement du scrutin de relaxation
donc dans un vase clos Patrice de façon
isolée si l'élection avait lieu
aujourd'hui monsieur Biden aurait
immensément de difficultés à être élu à
on évolue pas dans un vase clos et je
veux dire on ne vole pas dans une
situation normale on évolue dans une
situation où son adversaire probable le
plus probable et quelqu'un qu'il peut de
façon très réaliste espère espérer
battre c'est-à-dire l'homme dont on a
passé l'équation 6 dernières minutes à
parler monsieur Trump merci beaucoup
Raphaël bonne fin de ceci incroyable
c'est presque la politique fiction tout
ça merci beaucoup bonne fin de semaine à
vendredi prochain en principe au revoir